welcome to episode 26 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with jocko
willink he really needs no introduction
but real quickly if you don't know him
jaco willink is an american retired
naval officer
who served in the navy seals he's a
podcaster and an author
he's co-authored the books extreme
ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership with fellow
retired ceo leif babin
and a number of awesome kids books like
mikey and the dragons
he's co-founded the management
consulting firm echelon front
he hosts a weekly podcast with brazilian
jiu jitsu practitioner echo charles
called the jocko podcast he's a
leadership guru
as you guys may know the only people who
have made me nervous on podcasts so far
have been navy seals so here's another
episode of me being nervous
maybe i managed to hide at this time i
literally ran through the questions i
wanted to ask him in 20 minutes because
of how straightforward he is
and then i sat there and thought okay
just have a normal conversation
you can do this michaela just respond to
what he's saying
and stumbled through the rest we covered
some interesting topics though
about his self-publishing leadership
obviously how he met my dad
some of his experiences teaching
leadership skills to people
a story about why some people make it
through terrible situations and one why
some people don't mentally physically
i'm not used to being nervous which i've
told you guys a number of times
andre my husband pointed out after when
i was like what the hell is this weird
feeling that i have that's popped up
twice now
that maybe i don't feel lower on the
dominance hierarchy very often
and this is what it feels like i
certainly felt lower here
i hope you enjoy this episode but first
thanks to a few sponsors that made this
episode and this podcast possible
it's a jocko episode so there are a
number of people who wanted in on the
action
obviously thank you first of all to
merty creative
they create absolutely gorgeous leather
bound journals you can check them out on
instagram at
mertycreative.co or on their website
m-u-r-d-y-creative.co with the code
mp you can get a journal or other
leather goods
that are personalized with your name
engraved i currently have a brown
leather journal i keep by my bed that
says michaela on it
i've been using it to write down the
thoughts that go through my head before
bed so i don't have to blast my eyes
with my phone
right before i sleep if you need an
original gift idea
or you do any writing by hand i'd
recommend these journals
they also make leather binders and
folios check out marty creative.co to
see what they have and remember to use
code mp
for free personalization on any of their
products they also have pens leather
wallets bag tags glass cases
and a ton of other leather goodies very
american
very handmade and kind of old-fashioned
in a romantic way
check out mertycreative.co and use code
mp
for personalized leather products i'd
like to thank optimal carnivore for
sponsoring this episode
they make organ supplements if you're
low in vitamin d
i would recommend their liver supplement
a lot of people are low in vitamin d and
given the flu season and covid might be
something worth supplementing
using organ supplements is a great way
to do that and if you take a
multivitamin already
i would suggest switching it over to
something like what optimal carnivore
offers
it's way healthier and more bioavailable
than the usual multivitamins
a lot of what you use in regular
vitamins you actually just pee out
they have a bone marrow supplement a
liver supplement and a mix of nine
grass-fed organs
in one supplement these will not cause
health sensitivities as they're all
animal based including the capsule
for 10 off amazon.com optimal carnivore
that's optimal carnivore at amazon and
of course true local the canadian boxed
meat company that i use for my food
if you go to truelocal.ca that's tru
local.ca you can make a box of whatever
meat cuts you want and they'll deliver
it flash frozen to you
anything you'd like grass-fed
grass-finished beef grain finished beef
chicken pork wild fish like salmon lamb
spiced meat
i use them because they taste great and
i'm very picky about meat something that
happens if you only eat meat for years
it's almost been three years now
actually isn't that insane
they connect local farmers hence the
name true local so this is a way for
canadians to get locally farmed
sustainable meat
it's as vegan as you can get if you're
not a vegan use the code mp for free
steaks
and so they know where you've come from
and keep sponsoring me
that's truelocal.ca codemp for locally
and sustainably raised meat
enjoy the episode hopefully i'm not too
nervous and maybe you'll even learn
something
i certainly did
[Music]
thanks for having me on thank you so
much for joining
yeah it's always nice to chat via zoom
which is what the world has come to
now apparently uh when i
first learned more about you i thought
you were
this is really silly but i thought you
were ridiculously short
for a very long time because of how wide
your shoulders are
and it wasn't until my dad was like no
he's he's massive
he's like i thought i really thought you
were like five
four and just really tough
well that's interesting a lot of times
when i meet people they say that i'm
smaller than they thought i was because
i'm 5 11. so you know sometimes i guess
maybe the way i appear on camera
looks look look like i'm larger so it's
interesting that you
in your mind saw me as this tiny
individual
you're not a tiny individual not exactly
but you're so
like broad it was hard to imagine that
he could be above 5'4
anyway i thought that was funny because
my dad was like nah michaela that's
wrong
so um okay well i
just if i'm allowed i would like to just
throw a bunch of questions at you
because i have a
whole bunch of things i'd like to learn
about let's do it
okay i actually wanted to start with
you've been self-publishing
children's books i know because you sent
me a couple of them which i loved
is there a reason you decided to go with
self-publishing
well so i haven't self-published all my
children's books here's what happened
i wrote a book called way the warrior
kid that was published on
a regular publishing company an imprint
under macmillan
publishing called fine well and friends
which is a very cool
very very good group and so that was
where i did my first children's book
then i did my second children's book
which is the second book in the series
of way of the world
warrior kid and then i
was going i wrote a book called mikey
and the dragons and i wanted to publish
mikey and the dragon so in august i told
my publisher hey i've got another book i
want to put it out by christmas
i just kind of thought no big deal you
know we'll put it out by christmas
and they said well you know we can't get
it out by christmas
and i said no but i really want to get
it out by christmas and they said
well you know we got to get the sales
cycle and
the printers lined up and i said well
the book's already done you know we just
need to get it to a printer and
and this went on for a little while and
and then finally they said
they said there is no scenario where
this
book comes out by christmas and i said
are you sure yes and i said okay
watch this and i started a publishing
company and the book came out for
thanksgiving
as a matter of fact so once i did that
and then you realize you know i mean
it's not
rocket science you know um it's it's
it's printing paper which we've been
doing for a very long time
so once you figure that out you can get
it done and then i put my next kids book
out
on jocko publishing but then i had my
latest book called leadership strategy
and tactics
came out on st martin's press which is
who published my
other adult books and they've just given
me great deals
so yeah i i think it's a good thing to
have
in my back pocket and i've also got i've
got some books coming out from other
authors now
that maybe you know i can give them a
better deal and give them better support
than they might get at a
at a traditional publisher so it's cool
you know it's um
it's a good business it's a tough
business it's a good business but when
you kind of
when you have the mechanisms to put it
all together
it's a lot easier than it would be if i
was you know a person that had never
written a book before and decided i was
gonna start a publishing company
it would be a lot harder yeah yeah okay
um so you wake up at 4 30 in the morning
i do and you do that every single day
i actually do yeah i do so what time do
you go to bed in order to make that
happen
10 30 11 o'clock something like that and
do you nap
um if i'm if i feel tired i
i will take a nap i'll take about uh
eight to ten minute nap
you know oh that was not a very long nap
yeah i don't know if you've ever tried
it elevate your feet above your heart
so like lay down put your feet up on a
couch or something lay down on the floor
set your alarm clock for 10 minutes if
you're really tired you'll fall asleep
really quickly and
when you wake up you'll feel like you
just slept for six hours it's awesome
okay i used to do that when i was
studying because i heard it's a good way
to remember things if you just fall
asleep for a little bit
i don't remember who it was someone
won't comment but there was a scientist
who used to hold marbles
and as soon as he fell asleep the
marbles would drop
and that was enough time to convert i
guess short-term memory into long-term
memory
you didn't need very much time yeah i
like it
um okay i so i read your book extreme
ownership
actually i read both i read the newest
book too um i needed to prepare
it was like i better know what i'm doing
so i read the books
um how do you avoid becoming too much of
a tyrant
to yourself like if you i mean you
strike me as someone who's extremely
high in conscientiousness and sometimes
you can end up
pushing yourself past what you should
push yourself do you have
boundaries do you know when to stop
pushing yourself like if you get sick or
something or
so with being a leader and with being a
human being you you have to maintain
balance and if you go extreme in any
direction and anything if
even if you take the most positive
attribute
of a human if you take it to an extreme
it becomes a negative so what does that
mean you have to pay attention to it
like being
being conscientious right that's a great
attribute for people to have
can they take it too far where it drives
them insane yes
so just like any other attribute that a
person might have
you wanna you wanna maintain some level
of balance and
so if i if i see that i'm starting to
get out of control
you know where i'm not paying attention
to my family enough because i'm working
too much
oh okay yeah don't do that spend spend
some more time with the family
um so i i think it's just a matter of
paying attention to it and maintaining
balance
yeah do you get do you get guilty if you
don't work
if if you put i i g i have a problem i
guess
mainly at my problem with guilt is if
i'm if something is taking time
away from me working and and so then i
have guilt issues with oh i'm not
spending enough time at home or i'm not
doing enough of this or i'm not getting
enough
done i'm not accomplishing as many
things as i could accomplish
is there are there signs for whether or
not that guilt is necessary
or are there signs you have so that you
know if you're accomplishing what you
should be
i i think i just kind of like what i'm
doing and
that includes both hanging out with my
family and includes surfing it includes
working out and includes working
so i don't really you know for me it all
balances out pretty good and
i'm i'm stoked if i'm hanging out
playing guitar
you know with my family or if i'm right
sitting down recording a podcast it's
all good to me and i have to pay enough
attention to it that
you know i could get focused more on one
than the other so i just just need to
pay a little bit of attention it's not
like i
need to go crazy about it but a lot of
good things in life and i like doing
them and i
if there's anything that i've probably
been able to do relatively decently it's
removed things from my life that i don't
really like that much
so i maybe i've done a good job of doing
that at this point i mean look i was in
the military for 20 years and when
you're in the military you're
going to spend time doing things that
you don't particularly enjoy
and you know at this point in my life i
guess i'm older now
and i've i've gotten to a point where
i've eliminated
a decent amount of those things that i
don't like doing oh
that's good it's a good place to aim
towards not bad
um you talk a lot about friends and the
importance of having
support how are people supposed to make
friends that will actually be there when
things get tough like i've
my husband is russian and it seems like
perhaps that cultures the bonds that
russians make seem to be stronger than
the bonds that north americans
make just on average um they'll
if the going gets tough you can call on
friends and they'll show up
and i've had not personally necessarily
but
lots of my friends have issues with not
having a support system
is there a way people can look for
proper friends to build a support
network
yeah i mean i i think that a majority of
my friends have come
from environments where the people that
i become friends with are people that
i'm doing hard things with
so whether that's being in the military
and going on deployment and going
through hard training those people
become my friends and
then really the rest of my friends are
people that i pretty much know from
doing jiu jitsu
and so that's another thing where you're
training hard you're choking each other
and over time you realize that that
person has
some level of fortitude and they'll be
there if you need them
so you know i don't have a ton of
friends
um it's probably a pretty short list
i've got a lot of acquaintance and i've
got a lot of good acquaintances but
i don't but you know i just have a few
you know a few good friends that if i
call them
they'll be there and they know the same
thing's true about me if and and i'm not
a great communicator either you know i
don't have friends and
i don't send birthday cards i don't send
birthday texts
i don't say hey i'm going to be in town
for night do you want to go catch dinner
i don't want to bother people uh and and
you know i have had friends very good
friends you know i was
i was stationed in san diego california
and i had a
uh my i guess you would say he was my
best friend
we went through seal training together
we went to seal team one together
we did three sealed deployments together
and then we went to the training
department together
and that entire time we were roommates
and then i went and got stationed in
virginia beach and when i went and got
stationed in virginia beach this was
1998
i didn't talk to him i didn't talk to
him for two years and then i came back
to california
and there he was we you know we
high-fived and everything was like
totally normal
so i'm not great at keeping up contact
with people but if you're my friend and
you call me i'll be there
yeah well my next question was going to
be if you don't do something like navy
seals or if you're not in the military
where do you go to find people like that
but you said jiu jitsu
yeah i think you know the jujitsu
community i
i know it might sound kind of weird to
be really
that supportive of jiu jitsu but it
really is an awesome sport it's an
awesome thing to do for a multitude of
different reasons
so yeah if you are stuck in a place
where you're not really meeting people
and you're looking for some people that
you can bond with
go to jiu jitsu academy and start
training jiu jitsu and
you'll start making some friends yeah do
something hard
yeah cool okay um what does your diet
look like
uh you know i eat a lot of steak
and i eat a lot of caesar salads
and sometimes i have some other forms of
salad sometimes i eat chicken
um like that kind of stuff you know as a
big uh joke
on twitter uh before you made the lion
diet all
popular you know my response to any food
questions
was steak so uh yeah
i i think that's funny and and i was you
know i was kind of joking
you know but i also kind of i'm not
joking like that's legitimately
i i eat a ton of of steak you know when
i hunt you know so i eat elk as well
uh but yeah you know i eat a lot of
steak a lot of meat
you know just normal kind of like the
normal modern
like hey i don't eat a bunch of sugar
you know i have a
i make supplements so i have awesome
protein uh
you know so just just kind of normal
like don't eat don't eat freaking cakes
what's up yeah yeah okay that's what i
figured
i was um i went out for dinner tonight
with my family and was like i did
he doesn't strike me as the type of guy
i was like yeah i'll have like a little
bit of moose with this
uh so yeah i figured steak but that's
cool
what were you like as a teenager as a
teenager i was a rebellious kid
i was really into hardcore music i lived
on the east coast i went to
hardcore music shows up and down the
east coast
and yeah didn't you know i was just a
rebellious
knucklehead kid causing trouble and
then eventually the most rebellious
thing that i could do was
being from a small new england town was
join the military so that's what i did
wow so is that something you had in your
mind like years and years before you
joined the seals
or is that something that you just did
yeah i i always wanted to be
some kind of commando when i was a
little kid i think i got really really
lucky
because it's just what i wanted to do
and if you you know you see little kids
that
they want to be a fireman or they want
to be a policeman or they want to be a
business banker or
whatever they want to be i mean people
have those little goals when they're
kids
and i just legitimately just wanted to
be
some kind of commando and then lo and
behold
as soon as i figured out that you can
actually do that
it was a no-brainer and then i never i
like i played war when i was a kid and
then when i got older i kept playing war
never had to grow up
wow uh what does get some mean
get some well it's
it's means you're gonna about to do
something hard generally
and so don't shy away from it go and do
the thing that's
that you have to do that's probably
going to be hard
the the stand by to get some we were
actually i was with
i was over on deployment in iraq and we
were in a
in a city that was going a little bit
sideways and there were some
some people in the city the civilians
were starting to gather and start to
protest
and we had to actually drive through
this area
and so we had stopped and we were kind
of observing and we saw
things starting to escalate and so i
made i said but we had to go
and so i got on my radio it was daytime
oddly enough and so i got on my radio
and i said mount up mount up mount up
which meant everyone who had been out of
the vehicles and security positions
got back in the vehicles and then i just
said stand by to get some
and you know everybody knows it's sort
of a it's sort of uh
a little tongue-in-cheek because you
know you're going to a tough situation
and it's like stand by to get some so
yeah
uh this i'm going to try and stumble
through this question um
something that really i didn't really
know what the difference is between men
and women were
because i just thought everyone was like
me
until i was like 26. um but
after speaking with like a number of men
particularly my husband
i've know and i think you talked about
it in your book a bit is that something
men seem to do is look at other men
and emulate behaviors that they
that they think i guess represents
somebody dominant or
traits they think are useful right
is kind of learn from learn from people
and emulate behaviors i think are useful
and i don't think that that's something
women do
as much so i'm wondering if you had it's
just not like
my husband for instance told me that he
learned from
other men that he respected and that he
would take on kind of traits that they
had
and i thought well that's insane why
would you change
yourself and it's not why wouldn't you
grow because people want to grow but it
was like how can you change who you are
and so is that something that men do is
take on traits that they
think are strong is that
i i don't know if it's something
that just men do i i mean i can't speak
for being a woman
yeah i am not you know although i do
have three daughters and one son
and i definitely see my daughters you
know kind of looking around and
and when they see something they're
older now you know 20 and 19 or the
older ones and i still have
one 11 year old but i i think it's uh
i i know i did it you know i know that i
looked not only to emulate traits of
people that i saw that were positive but
also
to steer away from when i had a leader
that i was working for that
had you know a big ego or treated people
he
treated people bad i would instinctively
and proactively try not to do that so
i think it's just a good human behavior
and whether or not it's male female i'm
not really 100 sure
i just think it's a i think it's a
positive human behavior as long as
you're trying to
lean towards good good traits that
you're seeing in other people and
lead away from bad traits well certainly
avoiding
being an [ __ ] is always a good idea
um
have you have you ever experimented with
hallucinogens
i have not no no
i i guess you know some i guess one time
going through seal training you stay
awake for extended period of time
and everyone says that you have all
these hallucinations
and i i sort of might have had
one but it i was like oh i'm just seeing
that because i'm really tired
and it was like i was we were paddling a
boat in the ocean and i saw a stop sign
and a stop light and then i would i just
thought to myself oh i'm just seeing
that because i'm tired it wasn't
it wasn't like i believed it or anything
yeah so no i don't think i've ever had
any sort of real
hallucination at any time how long were
you awake
uh you know you spend maybe five
and a half days or something like that
and you do get a little
bits of sleep maybe an hour here or half
hour there
but that does not sound like that
doesn't sound great
well it's it's it's not that big of a
deal i mean you're doing stuff and
you're they're feeding you and you're
carrying boats around so you're just
doing physical labor that you can handle
for an extended period of time it's not
that big of a deal
you know no five days it sounds like
you'd feel pretty wired at the end of
that
i was tired i was looking forward to
going to sleep when i was done and then
i i recovered really well really quickly
it's fun
um okay for people who aren't
disciplined sometimes discipline doesn't
come naturally to people
um are there suggestions to increase
your ability to become disciplined
yeah but nobody likes them you know i
always say wake up early
and do something physical when you get
out of bed you know wake up early
no one wants to do that or at least most
people don't want to do that but i think
it's a good cornerstone for discipline
because it kind of gets your day
off on the right foot and i can just
about guarantee you that if you
wake up early and you do some exercise
you'll feel better for the rest of the
day and then
hopefully when you get to the end of
that day you're a little bit more tired
earlier which means you go to bed
earlier which means it's a little easier
to wake up early the next day and
and then you do some exercise that day
and you feel good again and then
at the end of that day you're even a
little bit more tired even a little bit
earlier so
instead of staying up until two o'clock
in the morning on whatever watching
netflix you're going to bed at a normal
time and waking up early so
you know i think that's just just start
waking up early and the other thing is
you know if
if you're really having a hard time with
it write down what it is you're supposed
to do and then go do
it it's it's pretty easy to plot out
what you know you should do to sort of
move yourself in the right direction
and it's not really hard to come up with
that list of things that you know you
should do
so write them down and then go and do
them
yeah okay okay i i get that question
sometimes when people ask me how i can
only eat meat
i was like well the alternative was
worse and i just kind of decided to do
it and then
i sucked it up yeah well that's good
yeah um okay what about braver there's i
find okay
what's going on right now with um the
states and the protests and everything i
get a lot of messages if i ever put up
anything political
about people saying people message me
and they go oh like
i agree with you it's a direct message i
agree with you but i can't say anything
i can't talk about it um do you have any
lessons to
get people to be braver i guess about
talking
about their opinion rather than i think
that's part of the problem with what's
going on
right now in north america as people are
scared to say anything
yeah i i think that
not only are people sometimes scared to
say anything but they're also
really not listening to each other and
that's one of the problems that
that we have in this country right now
is if somebody says something that
that you don't 100 agree with
then you're just going to block out
everything else that they have to say
and you're not going to listen to
anything else they have to say and
actually
you might attack them you know you might
call them a communist
or a racist or whichever end of the
spectrum you want to put them on
you know or whichever end of the
spectrum you're on from your position
so we have a problem not just with
talking but we have a problem with
listening and a lot of that i think
stems from the fact that
we all have an inflated sense of ego
about what's right and what's wrong and
we all think that we actually know
i actually know what's right and what's
good and
whoever else is talking if they're not
100 in agreement with me then
then i should attack them because
they're wrong and i'm right
so i think that's what we have and
that's what causes someone
when they feel like hey if i say
something
i'm going to be attacked and and then
they're nervous so they just don't say
anything well they might not have that
strong
of a feeling about what they're going to
say or they might be actually
questioning what they're
thinking and if you open your
conversation if i open my conversation
by
saying i'm 100 percent right about the
following
thing i'm probably going to get attacked
but
but if i say hey what do you think about
this or
how does this play out in a scenario
where whatever
instead of making statements maybe if
you ask them questions about it
it would open up a conversation instead
of making people dig into
their trenches on their personal beliefs
yeah that's definitely true you say i
think before
whatever statement that that works
fairly well although my dad used that
trick and it was
people were still pretty hard on him
even though he was like ah i'm still
working this out but
i think i think this is what's going on
yeah yeah yeah i mean you know
he he would you know your dad would have
very honest little phrases to use you
know
from my perspective or as far as i'm
concerned so he's
he's putting a caveat on there like i'm
not really 100 sure about
this thing that i'm saying and and
that's good because
it's it's a way of saying listen if you
come to me and you actually can provide
me with
more clarification to that i can see
a a point from a different angle more
power to you
right i'm happy i'm happy to learn and
there's nothing wrong with that
so i think what we have to do and the
other thing that i think
you have to be careful of nowadays is
because you know that the
whoever you're talking to there's a
there's a relatively good chance that
they're are they are dug into an
entrenched position
and that if they see anything other than
what they want to see
they're going to attack it and if they
attack it then we're not having a
conversation
because you know if you believe the sky
is green and i believe the sky is blue
and the first thing i say to you is hey
michaela
you don't know what you're talking about
you're an idiot the sky is blue
you're just stupid what is your chance
of listening to anything that i say
from there on out i'll tell you the
chance is zero you're just gonna hate me
and we're not gonna come to
any agreement but if i say hey michaela
i understand you think that the sky is
green
let me ask you something because from my
perspective it looks blue
but i was wondering what does a leaf on
a tree
look like what color do you call that
right and and now i'm actually asking
you a real question because
i want to understand your perspective
better because
if you say you know that that tree leaf
is blue now i know that you see things
different than me
and now we need to have a conversation
and maybe we can make some progress
so i i think these days in order to
in order to cautiously move through the
world
and have good conversations with people
you need to be
cautious in your approach
to make sure that when you speak your
mind
you're doing it in a way that allows
other people
to see that your mind isn't made up
and that you're open and and i'm not
just saying that
so that you can trick them i'm actually
like there's very few things that i can
tell you michaela 100
i know this forever is 100 there's not
too many things like that
right um you know you spend all kinds of
time
debating uh what people should eat right
and
and there's people look we could go on
the internet right now
and find legitimate sources for
absolutely anything
so that's and that's true with
everything
that you can think of so if all we want
to do is argue
cool put your stake in the ground and
get attacked if you
actually have an open mind and you want
to hear what other people have to say
and here are the points of view
which if you have an open mind those
things will help you
gain a better perspective of your own
view maybe change it a little bit maybe
adjust it maybe strengthen it
but if you don't go into situations with
an open mind it's going to be hard to do
that
yeah yeah i found some of the stances i
took when i was
like yes younger and more naive uh
when i was 100 certain about things
totally screwed me over later
it was only well i got screwed over a
number of ways but
it was mainly the things i was
absolutely positive about
that just flipped me upside down like
first it was i used to make fun of
gluten-free people all the time
and it turned out i it turns out part of
my autoimmune disorder is a reaction to
gluten it was like
joke's on you so that was the first
thing and then i
and then and then i went on an all-meat
diet which is
all like which was just impossible for
me to understand how anyone could even
survive like that and i was like i can't
be 100 sure about
anything anymore just in case the
universe is really weird
but you set yourself in stone in one
direction and it'll just
flip itself that's what i've experienced
anyway this is a dangerous
idea yep and it's also really hard to
have conversations with people when they
think that you
are 100 sure because then if you think
you're 100 they're not having a
conversation they're just attacking you
and that's what they're going to do
they're not even trying to feed you any
information they're just 100 attacking
you so
it's definitely interesting times yeah
yeah that's for sure it's definitely
interesting times um okay
how do you you've been in extremely
stressful situations like
life-threatening situations
are there techniques you use to keep
your mind
clear in stressful situations or does
that just come naturally
it's it's a process of detaching
and it's a manual process that i i
originally did i talked about it in that
book leadership strategy and tactics i
was in the
training situation there's no war going
on but i was in a training situation
we were clearing this oil platform
and came up on this level of the
platform where my whole platoon got
online ready to clear this thing and i'm
staring down the
barrel of my gun looking down the sights
and i'm waiting for
one of my leadership inside my platoon
to make a decision to make a tactical
call
and no one's saying anything so i'm
sitting there waiting
and i'm looking down you know looking
down the sights of my weapon and
i'm waiting and no one's making a call
and i'm waiting and no one's making a
call and finally i just
said i better like look around and see
what's going on
so i stepped back i looked to my left i
looked to my right and what i saw was
every other person in my platoon
is all staring down their weapon at the
you know
down looking for targets and then i
could see what we needed to do because i
was actually
took a step back i was detached and
looking around and then i
made a very simple tactical call and
everyone executed it
and i realized that i was a new guy and
i realized that the reason i was able to
figure out what to do was because i was
detached
i wasn't all wrapped up in that
emotional moment
and staring down my the the sights of my
weapon and so
that became the way i started to operate
you know and we don't make good
decisions when we're emotional we don't
make good decisions
when we're backed up in the fire fight
you need to take a step back
and so in stressful situations what do i
do
i take a step back i look around i you
know i don't scream and yell
and you know i might have to raise my
voice if i'm talking over machine gun
fire
but i don't scream and yell and panic i
take a step back you know if i'm talking
on the radio
it's a it's uh a point of pride right in
the military that if there's crazy
things happening when you key up your
radio to say something
you don't say hey i need help out here
right now you know
no you say hey this is jock owen
building 2-4 we need immediate fire
support in this area
and everyone goes okay cool he's calm
he's got it going on
so just take a step back detach don't
freak out
don't get emotional if you start feeling
yourself get emotional
then you need to you need to do just
that take a step back
take a breath don't panic and calm down
yeah that's fair i've got i've had this
this year's
just been insane and i've
had a lot of practice trying to force
myself to stay
calm or to detect detach which i think
is also something that might happen
kind of automatically if you're in a
very high stress situation
in order to be able to continue thinking
right i think if you're lucky it happens
if you're i mean well look
you either know to do it or you
get lucky like for me i'd say the first
time it happened in that little
stressful situation
i was lucky that it happened because
then i figured out it was an actual path
i could
choose but and i think you're right i
think some people
you know uh mayhem breaks out and
there's some people instinctively they
go wait a second i better not panic
right now and that's
good and hopefully they recognize that
that's a path they can take doesn't
always happen though you know when you
you know you hear some of the
i'll tell you you know when i work with
like police officers and
you hear some of the radio calls
and they're saying that's not fired
shots fired i'm saying does this person
sound like they've got their emotions
under control the answer is no
so we need to learn to control our
emotions and and your voice is a very
good indicator
of where your stress levels are at so i
always used to tell the young seals like
hey
if you're screaming and yelling on the
radio or you're screaming and yelling at
your people
that means that's an indicator that you
need to calm down because you're losing
your mind and that is not a good way to
make decisions
yeah it's not it's definitely not
helpful to get out of the stressful
situation if that's the goal
no doubt yeah so i have a friend who's
in the seals
and he said him and some of the people
he's spoken with
have been concerned about the amount of
attention
in the last i guess 10 years that the
seals have been getting because people
are coming out and talking about some of
the experiences they've had
in the seals and so i was wondering
is there an amount because discussing
war is complicated right because
a lot of the stuff that goes on there
people can't hear about because it's
terrifying and it's you know so is there
like a limit of what you decide to share
and what you think is appropriate to
share versus not
well as far as what's terrifying and
whether people should hear or hear about
it or not i
i actually think people should hear
about how awful and horrible and
terrible and terrifying war
is because if you don't know those
things then
you sit there and say hey it seems like
it's a good idea to go
invade this country or go to war in this
region and
you're not the one that's going to be
going to do that and you have no idea
what it's like and you have no problem
sending a
you know an 18 year old kid over there
to do it and see all that terrible thing
see all those terrible things well
that's i don't think that's right so
as far as where i put my filter on
the terror and horror of war i'd i will
not put a filter on that and
you know listen to my podcast you'll
hear you know not just from me
and but from from the past
wars and current wars and people
explaining how
terrible and awful it is and then as far
as
you know the limits of information being
put out yeah there's very clear
limits of information being put out and
that is what's
what's classified if there's anything
that could
help the enemy or hurt america
then i would never talk about it and
that's yeah pretty straightforward as
far as i'm concerned
of course um did did joining the
military
fundamentally change aspects of your
personality going through what you went
through
i i think i just like anyone else you
know got older and got more mature and
i certainly didn't join the military and
all of a sudden
i will i you know was a totally
different person it took
time but you know you go you undergo
experiences and
you learn more about human nature you
learn more about yourself and i would
say i grew and matured
and and i think possibly that the
military
and certainly war will accelerate some
of that
maturation a bit because you're seeing
things you know
i i mean i i was talking to my
mom maybe six months ago or something
like that and
they you know she's she was telling me
that it's been a tough year because
she's had
four of her friends die
right and you know she you know she was
just saying it's been a tough year and i
said
you know how how old were they and she
said oh you know they were 75
80 years old and you know i i said
that's awesome they got to live full
lives and for the last
two decades i've been saying goodbye to
my friends that died when they were
25 years old and 27 years old and 32
years old
so i think war you're gonna see a
concentration
of life experiences in a compressed
time zone and and so maybe it makes you
mature a little bit quicker
in some ways and i mean in other ways
maybe it keeps you
a little bit mentally stunted in growth
uh you know you become a little bit
institutionalized you know and
you know you're you you have a mission
and that's when you're in the military
you kind you you have a mission you have
something that you're trying to do you
have a direction that you're going in
and so a lot of guys when they get out
of the military they don't have a
mission anymore and that can be hard
because they've been they've had the
institutionalized mission
in life and that makes everything so
nice and easy when you wake up in the
morning and you know what
you're here for when you get out of the
military you wake up and all of a sudden
you might not know what you're here for
and that can be a problem
but other than that i don't think it
changed me rapidly it maybe compressed
the
the maturity level that i had into a
shorter time period
yeah i suppose it also gives you a bar
of
what bad is like uh because i think
there are a lot of people
particularly now because north america
has
been such a great place for a number of
decades that people
don't know what suffering looks like
necessarily i mean lots of people do
in various degrees but i suppose it
probably gives you a pretty good
low bar for identifying what real
suffering is
which is probably helpful just to know
well it definitely gives you an
understanding of human beings propensity
for evil
and to commit total horror and
atrocities
absolutely which is as you said it's
good to know that
because if you don't know that then
maybe you think
you don't really need to protect
yourself or your
family or your community or your country
from those types of behaviors
but when you see them you think yourself
yeah
we we need to we need to be on the
lookout
at some level yeah um one of the things
that i i read in your book that i hadn't
thought about
um and i remember doing it as a kid was
you wrote about having
like exit strategies for your house
things and just knowing what to do in an
emergency and teaching your kids what to
do in an emergency
and i haven't that's not something i
thought about i i remember we used to
have a plan
when i was really little when i lived in
boston and then
i didn't think of it until i read your
book so that's something you tell people
to do right
just prepare for worst case scenarios
just so
you know what to do when they happen if
they happen god forbid
yep and probably what happened is you
lived in boston and maybe it was a new
neighborhood and your
your dad looked around and said hey you
know what this is you know we could have
a fire here or we could have a break in
you know there's all these people
and it's america and it's a little crazy
and so your dad said you know what we
need to come up with a plan and then you
came up with a plan and guess what
nothing ever happened hopefully
and so nothing ever happened and then
all of a sudden it's like well you get
to your next place and you move back to
canada
and in canada everyone's so nice and
you're not worried about it no one locks
the door
yeah and all of a sudden we don't need
any uh a planet anymore but
yes i would recommend figuring out what
your action strategy
is going to be in those situations and
is that for if some like
is that for an intruder or a fire or do
you just cover everything
yeah intruder fire and you can you want
you actually want those plans to be as
similar as possible
so basically when you make the call
everyone kind of knows what they're
going to do and
it's pretty much the same plan and you
rehearse the plan a few times and then
you got something to fall back on in
case something goes wrong
okay back to the children's books for a
sec uh what made you decide to
write those well i have four kids
and as i would go out
to try and find books for my children to
read
i realized that there was very few if
any books that actually
that actually made any attempt to teach
and imbue the values that i
thought would be good for them to have
i those kind of books didn't really
exist and so i said okay well i'll just
write them
pretty pretty straightforward yeah fair
enough there's one book
kind of um oh god can i even remember
what it was
there's no such thing as dragons have
you read that one
it's pretty good it's it's not kind of a
hero story but
it's about a kid his parent isn't seeing
the dragon there's a little tiny dragon
under the rug
and the dragon grows and grows takes
over the entire house
my that was one of my dad's favorite
stories to reach me as a kid
so that's a good one um okay that was
one of your dad's favorite
stories to read yeah yeah of course
right it's like
a hidden dragon yeah we read that a lot
um okay
what else do i have to ask you who are
people who inspire you
you know there's all kinds of people um
you know
and just i guess by nature of my
my occupation in my former occupation
you know i know all
kinds of individuals that have had all
kinds of just
incredibly horrific injuries
and they wake up every day and
they go do what they're supposed to do
and any time
i feel a complaint creeping up in my
mind about
i don't feel good or i've got to soar
this or i'm busy because of that
i just need to think of any number of
those individuals and realize that
you know what i'm gonna be just fine go
go and
go and get after it yeah um why why do
you think some people
can be horrifically injured and then
recover from that psychologically and be
like you know thank god i'm still here
or thank god there isn't more pain
instead of being like you know i've
i'm gonna have a limp forever and woe is
me because not everyone else has this
limp
what's the difference between those
people so
i i did a i did a series of podcasts
about there's a there's a guy named
chesty puller
who is the most iconic us marine of all
time
he's the recipient of five navy crosses
he
fought in in world war ii and korea
and everybody just loves this guy in
fact when you go through marine corps
boot camp
when you go to bed at night you sing a
song
good night chesty so this and as a
matter of fact the
the mascot of the marine corps to this
day is a bulldog whose name is chesty
so this guy's the most iconic marine
ever
and he had a son and his son was
not quite cut from the same cloth as his
dad he was
a little bit more cerebral he wore
glasses
he was kind of a slight guy and
he ended up going to college and when he
got done with college he wasn't quite
sure what he was going to do
and so he you know he had grown up with
his dad on marine corps bases
and he got done with college and he went
well i guess i'll join the marine corps
and he actually his vision wasn't good
enough to join the marine corps
so he had to get a little bit of help
getting in the marine corps from his dad
and he ended up getting in the marine
corps
and once he's in the marine corps as a
young officer
it's 1968 and i think
he goes to officer candidate school the
basic school gets 13 days to leave and
then he gets taken over to vietnam and
he's a platoon commander in vietnam
he's there he
eventually he gets horrifically wounded
he loses both of his legs his hands are
severely damaged
it's it's like he's going to die and
miraculously he survives this he makes
it back to america
he has to go through incredible you know
surgeries to try and keep him alive and
he lost his legs you know like basically
at the hip
um his he just is in really bad shape
he starts to drink he's on painkillers
it's a total nightmare by the way he had
when he left his wife was pregnant so
now he's got a kid
and it's just total chaos in mayhem
eventually
he kind of turns his life around he
stops drinking
he runs to become a state representative
in virginia
um he loses he runs as a democrat
and he loses to a republican war hawk
who had never been in the military and
got deferments from the draft and he
lost to that guy
he starts drinking again eventually his
wife says hey you know what i've had
enough of this
you you know you need to go to rehab
goes to rehab and while he's in rehab
someone says you need to write a
you know you need to write these things
down get him out of your system he
writes a book the book is called
fortunate sun it wins a pulitzer prize
it's a beautiful book
that's the book that i covered on my
podcast and as the book closes out
the vietnam war memorial is being
dedicated
and he kind of had a hand in helping it
come to fruition and he's at the
dedication
and after the dedication he goes to a
a party where there's a bunch of other
marines
and for the first time you know
while he's meeting people instead of
people saying what's wrong with you or
what happened to you why are you in a
wheelchair
they're just a bunch of marines they
know exactly what happened to him
and the only thing they really say to
him is welcome home
brother and that's where the book ends
and like i said the book comes out wins
a pulitzer prize and
um two years later i think he fell out
of his wheelchair
broke his hip they take him to the
hospital
um they put him back on painkillers it
sends him right down the addiction
spiral his wife leaves him
and he ends up killing himself jesus
and so i did a podcast about that
i did a podcast about his dad i did a
podcast about hit that guy his name is
lewis puller
and then i had a marine on a current
marine who is a
multi-generational marine who had also
lost a leg
and you know severely wounded but
i had a guy i had a guy on my podcast
later
whose name is jim searlsley and jim
sursley
was a normal american kid in 1960
whatever
not really sure what to do after high
school he likes working on cars
he thinks he might get drafted so he
joins the army he becomes a tank
mechanic
he gets stationed in germany and in
germany guess what there's no war going
on he's over there he's going to do his
couple years but he feels like
he's not making the commitment that he
should make so
he so he says hey i want to go to
vietnam volunteers to go to vietnam
and he ends up going to vietnam he's in
a vietnam for 11 months
and just as he's like reaching the point
where he's gonna be heading home soon
he steps on um a landmine
and it blows off both of his legs
and it blows off one of his arms so he
has one arm
and he comes home and he's on my podcast
you know i'm talking to him and
you know he's kind of explaining you
keep waiting for sort of the
the the the the tension and the and the
sadness to come out his voice and it
just doesn't come out
and he just he's just telling the story
as if he's talking about going to a
baseball game or whatever
and he comes home and he says yeah i had
to spend 90 months in rehab to learn how
to work for my wheelchair and then i
got out and i went to college and then i
started a roofing company
and i hired guys and then i started
getting into real estate and then i got
married and
and you know i had these kids and so he
just went through his normal life
and it's just this incredible story
and we got done with the podcast
and when we got done with the podcast
you know we were talking
and we were i was talking about the
basically the same question that you
just asked me it's like how
how did you just overcome all this
and he says to me he goes have you ever
heard of lewis puller
and i said yes sir absolutely i said i
did a podcast about him i know
everything that i could possibly know
about him
and he says you know i was in rehab with
him
and i said really and he said you know
here's what i think the difference is oh
i'm so ready for this yeah he said
i accepted 100
that this is what had happened to me and
that i just needed to carry on
i didn't complain about it i didn't say
what was me i didn't say why
why did this happen to me why couldn't
have been someone else why did i make
these decisions why did i volunteer to
go to vietnam why did i join the army
all those questions i
didn't ask them i accepted that what had
happened to me had happened to me and i
needed to move forward
and he said louise polar did his best
and he said i think he accepted 99
of what had happened to him and then he
that he just needed to move forward
but there was one percent of him that
was always saying
why did this happen to me this shouldn't
have been me i shouldn't have joined the
marine corps why did i do this why did i
do that
why didn't someone else move why should
why did that why was that land mine
there
the million reasons that cross your mind
when you think about the past and what
you would love to change about it but
you can't
so when you ask me that question
that's my answer is things are going to
happen
and you can regret them you can wish
that they didn't happen you can wish
that they go away
you can wish that you would have made a
thousand different decisions differently
but none of that changes the situation
that you're in so you have to look at
the situation that you're in
accept it and move forward
yeah okay that that's great that's great
those kind of people that
can go like most people have something
terrible happen to them in their life
and some people it's so bad
and they pop out of it like um there's
this i don't know if you know this
comedian her name is nicole arbour
and she's really funny and
i learned a little bit about her
background and she got into a car
accident and had chronic nerve pain for
years
and was bedridden with chronic nerve
pain and
she's better now and she's
just become a comedian cheerleader for
people
so she just tries to make the world a
better place
by joking about everything and there's
like zero resentment there
and there's no oh woe is me i had to
spend years in chronic pain
i missed out on part of my 20s like it's
just
i had an injury but like look how great
life is now
like it could have been so much worse
and it's like yeah those are the kind of
people you want to follow
yeah 100 and and by no means
am i even saying that you know hey i
i'm the guy that would be able to do
that if i was in this horrible situation
i mean
look i mean i've the worst things that
have happened to me is that i've lost my
friends
my my troops my men on the battlefield
and you know that that it is a
it is a thing that you can you can
definitely dwell on and
and you can let it drag you down if
you're not careful
and but i i that's why i use people that
like a guy like jim sursley who you know
he's
just had a horrific scenario unfold
and he faced it and he accepted it and
he moved forward and so
that's to me is just an example that i
can always look to to
to follow yeah that's a great example
i think part of the um when i when i was
in university there was a lot of
talk about if you had any type of
disability you could have extra time
or or use a computer or something and
i had pretty severe arthritis in my
wrist and all the tests were in the
morning so i couldn't use a pen
so i did use the computer but
it was like a third of the class that
had some sort of disability to
they get around things and i think part
of the problem with
that people are having with resentment
now is we're taught
that if there's any little thing that's
wrong
it's unfair and it shouldn't have
happened to you and which
could could be true it might be true
like
unfair things happen but instead of
being taught to just
get past it like that's a thing that
happened get past it
we're taught to dwell on it or blame
somebody and it's really
poisonous if you're trying to heal from
something rather than accepting it so
yeah yeah and you know i i ran into
those questions very early on after
my first book came out extreme ownership
and you know the
it's it's take ownership of everything
that's going on in your world
and don't blame anyone and don't make
any excuses and i was at a live event
and you know it's it's one of these
questions that
got asked very quickly as after that
book came out is you know
my 11 year old daughter has leukemia
how is how do i accept the blame for
that how do i take ownership of that
and the answer is is actually very
simple and straightforward
look you can't take ownership or
blame for your daughter getting leukemia
what you can do is take ownership of how
you respond to it
and if you respond to that by saying
okay this is what we're going to do this
is how we're going to move forward this
is this is where we're going to go this
is the things we're going to do
that's what you do you take ownership of
how you respond
and that's the best thing that you can
do in those situations so
yeah i mean it's it's really tough and
and you know and i've had many people
respond to me
that have been through that whether they
got a disease themselves
and said you know what look i can sit
here and say i'm a victim of this
disease or i can say okay
this is what i've got i'm going to take
ownership of how i respond i'm going to
do everything i can
that i'm able to do and and that is
absolutely the best attitude i've seen
and
and god bless those people that go
through those tough situations
and and they and they take the best
possible attitude and move forward
yeah well thank you very much for coming
on my podcast
i've been wanting to meet you for a
while so i was nervous i'm not usually
nervous
i've only been nervous twice really
three times i wasn't even nervous for
joe rogan but i also wasn't quite aware
of who joe rogan was
as much as i should have been uh i
probably would have been more nervous
but um
thank you very much for coming on and
thanks for sending me that kid's book
a while ago it's great thank you thanks
for having me it's good to talk to you
and uh please give
my best to your family uh you know i was
i was lucky enough to
sort of get involved in the in the
jordan peterson
thing before it was really a thing uh i
had him you know he was on my podcast
before
12 rules came out so he wasn't you know
people weren't really
you know how did you
find him before the book came out um i
follow
you know i just had seen some of his
stuff on youtube and then
we spoke at the same event in san diego
and i didn't see him speak because
i had another event so there was like a
two or three day event in san diego
i had been out of town i came back in
and went to speak at the event
and you're yeah and so i did a a
presentation about leadership and
leading
combat and and your dad asked me a
question
or two i think he actually asked me two
questions and
and we just ended up talking afterwards
and and i knew who he was you know like
i said i had i had seen
his videos and followed some of his
lectures and things so
so and he knew who i was somehow
i guess maybe through joe rogan so so
somehow we just
ended up talking and you know we got
along and then
we we linked up and he came on the
podcast in uh
2000 i guess it was 2017.
yeah it was i think we recorded in 2017
and
a long long podcast yeah yeah that was a
good one he talks about lunch bucket i
like that story
that's a good one oh i have one more
question this just popped into my head
okay so um i've been helping my dad with
his social like covering kind of the
social media aspect and
well you got in touch with me years ago
that's when i was doing his booking and
things
um and you talk with extreme ownership
about how there's no such thing as a bad
team just bad
leadership okay say you have a team
working underneath you
how do you identify because there are
definitely better workers and people who
are less capable
how do is there a quick way to identify
who's going to be
more trouble than they're worth well
it's very hard to identify that
without putting somebody in the position
that they're going to be in because
you look you could you can have an
interview every time i work with a
company i get asked a very similar
question that right someone will say
well how do we know what questions to
ask during an interview and what should
we use for a screening process
and i say okay how many people here have
hired someone
who did a great job in the interview and
their resume looked great
and they were horrible and everyone
raises their hand i said okay who here
has hired someone
who they didn't seem all that great they
were really not that good in the
interview but you needed to fill a seat
and you needed someone in that position
so you just took a chance and you hired
him and they turned out to be
outstanding and everyone raised their
hand again
so it's very difficult to know what
someone is
really like until you put them in the
position that they're going to be
working in
so you know you can you know you can
screen them the best you can you know
you can
ask for references you can talk to them
but you can talk to them instead of
saying
you know how long did you go to school
for and what did you study if you ask
them you know hey if well tell me about
a time in your life where you were in
charge of something
and it and you you weren't successful
and what went wrong
and and you know just questions like
that where you know if i say
well you know michael i was in charge of
you know this project
and it turns out that all the
contractors that worked on the project
were terrible and and not only that but
our supplies never showed up on time so
that's why we failed
and you can see when someone says that
even though they were in charge of the
project they're blaming the supply chain
and they're blaming
blaming the contractors and not taking
any ownership themselves now
if you were to say hey tell me about
something that you failed in and i said
well you know mikhail's in charge of
this project and we had a bunch of
contractors that work with us
but i didn't do a good job of really
keeping tabs of the contractors and how
well they were progressing through what
they were supposed to do
and on top of that our supplies showed
up late because i failed to order them
early enough
so what i learned from that was i needed
to make sure my supply chain was intact
and ready
and order stuff early enough that it
gets to us on time and number two
contractors i need to set up some kind
of a program or a standard operating
procedure where i was tracking what they
were doing to make sure that they were
gonna hit
the targets that we were trying to hit
so those are the things that i changed
in the future
and right there you can tell i mean who
who you're going to hire the person that
blames people the person that takes
ownership
yeah yeah that's true so that's extreme
ownership okay so say one one
one more then so say you've hired
someone and they
they do a couple of things wrong and you
have a feeling like
this is not good because i've made
mistakes hiring and then sometimes if
you hire someone who
isn't great then it can kind of infect
everything else
um how do you know when to fire them
like how do you know when they haven't
just made mistakes and they can learn
so there's a there's something called
the escalation of counseling
and what i mean by this is michaela's
working for me and
and you know you show up late for work
so
what do i do what do i do i i i
you know you're late for work that's not
good but do i jump down your throat and
write you up where now all of a sudden
you're like wait
what kind of an environment what kind of
a tyrannical environment am i working on
yeah
and what i do is i actually say hey hey
michaela
i noticed that you were late today and
you know i just want to make sure that
everything's okay i mean
is everything is everything all right
you know we're always on time here and
you weren't on time is everything okay
and there's a chance that you're like
well actually you know i
i had a flat tire in my car and that's
why i'm late i go oh okay cool
you know that's awesome yeah i'm glad
glad everything's okay
and and i even though i was nice and i
truly am concerned about you i mean
you work for me and i want to make sure
everything's okay this isn't just me
being sneaky it's me actually want to
make sure you're okay
and and now i find out just a flat tire
cool no problem
and and you also realize that
that you were late and that i realized
it so i'm kind of watching you you you
become aware of this in a very nice way
and maybe you're never late again
because you realize that that's not good
or maybe you're late next week and so
what do i do if you're late next week
well what i do is do i jump down your
throat and write you up no i say
hey michaela i noticed that you were
late again this week
obviously when you're late we're all
waiting on you that's a big waste of
time i mean is everything okay
and you say yeah you know i had a flat
tire well there was actually
construction and there was nails and i
swept them all up and it won't happen
but again i'm sorry
you know and i go okay great because it
really hurts our productivity when
you're not showing up on time you're
like i get it i get it sorry
and maybe that's enough i escalated a
little bit and now you're like jeez
that guy is tracking on me i don't want
to be late and maybe you're never late
again and that's great
or maybe you're late again and if you're
late again what am i gonna do i'm gonna
say michaela
you you're this is the third time being
late in three weeks and i understand
you've got things going on in your life
and guess what so does everyone else
we are not late and and this is crazy
because
i like you and you got potential but if
you're late again i'm actually gonna
have to write you
up for being late and i don't want to do
that because that's gonna be in your
record
and that's gonna hurt your potential
here so do me a favor
get up earlier if you have a flat tire
you can still make to work on time
do you understand where i'm coming from
and you go yes
you don't need to write me up i get it
it's okay and you get two more alarm
clocks
and you sweep your road every day and
you're not late again and maybe that's
awesome
and maybe the problem solved or maybe
it's not solved
and you're late again and now what am i
doing you're late again i'm actually
going to do what i said i was going to
do which is i'm going to write you up
and when i write you up i say hey
michaela here's what's going on here's
what your mistakes were and here are the
corrective measures that you need to
take
and here are the consequences if you
fail to
implement these corrective measures
and you say got it you sign your name
and you
don't want to ever be late again and you
get
four alarm clocks and you wake up early
and everything's good
or you're late again and if you're late
again guess what's gonna happen you're
not gonna be working here anymore
because i told you
where we feel bad as a leader is
when i don't escalate those
conversations
when i don't say anything and you get
away with being late
and i don't say anything because it's an
awkward conversation and then you're
late again and i don't say anything
because it makes me feel weird and i
don't want to
you know i don't want to get in a fight
with you and i want to you know as a
leader i want to build relationships and
if i'm yelling at you or if we're having
a confrontation then that's not good so
i i let it slide again
by the time you're late or you mess up
the project or you treat a client
whatever it is
i have to proactively have the hard
conversations
earlier because the earlier i have hard
conversations the easier they are
and what kind of a leader am i
if what i do when you make mistakes
is not talk to you about them look i
don't need to attack you
but i need to talk to you i need to
understand what why this is happening
what's going on what are you thinking
what have i not explained well enough
that you think it's okay to be late or
you think it's okay to
say this to a client right you work for
me
if you're not doing something correctly
that's actually my fault because i
haven't made it clear
what the standard is so
those are some things that you can do to
to
escalate and figure out when it is that
you need to get rid of somebody
and the final thing i'll say is look
when you work for me you're part of my
team
and i'm gonna i'm loyal to you and i'll
take care of you
but if i all of a sudden you start doing
things that negatively
impact the team and i start to have to
focus more of my time and effort on you
instead of the
other nine people on the team at some
point
my loyalty to the team and the mission
trumps my loyalty to you and i'm gonna
have to get rid of you
all right that was valuable god forbid
somebody's late to somebody who wakes up
at 4 30 in the morning that's not
ideal it's like no it's time
okay so like three chances escalation
and then
a little bit more of a serious
conversation with some consequences that
they know about
some potential consequences that they
will know about yeah okay that's good
and this is you know depending on the
industry that you're in or the situation
that you're and i work with some
industries where
those three chances happen in three days
and i work in other industries you know
if someone's a commission only sales
person
they'll let someone hang around for a
year because it's not costing them
anything
so it depends on your situation and and
you know the environment the dynamics
that you're working in you know maybe
it's
maybe it's five conversations maybe it's
two i don't know
okay that was very valuable thank you
right now
thank you well i'll let you know when
the episode's coming out but
thanks again that was nerve-wracking but
it was great it was nice to meet you
how can that be nerve-wracking i don't
know i'm
i don't get i don't get nervous i don't
know
it was you i had dan crenshaw on maybe
it has something to do with
navy seals i don't know what it is but i
don't get nervous i don't avoid hard
conversations like
i don't back away from things but like i
was a little nervous gotta admit
well i hopefully it wasn't as
nerve-wracking
as you had built it up to be hopefully
the dragons were smaller than they were
in your head
they were smaller awesome if you enjoyed
this episode
please rate it and leave a review if you
didn't enjoy it
please do not rate it and do not leave a
review
next week i'm speaking with dr bjorn
lomberg stay tuned for that
things like climate change come up in
environmentalism
hope you have a good week
[Music]
you